carl nassive announced on monday that he
is gay and he has had widespread support
from within
and without the national football league
his jersey according to fanatics
the highest selling across all fanatics
platforms
since he made that announcement and
uh you know that that's good that it
just shows you
the impact it shows you the message
it shows you the pride that people feel
from him
and the positive impact it can make on
the lives of others
who who are wrestling with
and you know i've heard from some people
and because i've said you know look the
nfl is 50 years behind
the rest of society and everywhere else
it's easy i heard from a couple people
said it's really
it's really not easy it's not it's not
as easy as you think
there are still pockets definitely you
know that's what i hope i was trying to
explain yesterday you still
you still dread you still dread
letting people know who you are because
of how they're going to react and it's a
shame that that's the case but
uh you know i guess i'm not
i guess i guess i'm really not surprised
by that depending upon
where you live uh i i guess i could see
that still being an issue
and that's i i i so i get it i get it
and and but the nfl is still behind
the locker room has always been behind
the rest of society
yeah a hundred percent always been
behind the rest of society in that
conversation but i mean i think as we're
seeing here and like you explained
yesterday
that even the nfl society has taken
major steps in the last 10 or 15 years
with the support he's gotten from his
own teammates other people around the
nfl
things like that but yeah is he still
going to have people in that locker room
that are going to be
you know side eyeing him a little bit
and some coaches who
you know of course are old school and
having adjusted their thoughts or
whatever else may be super religious
you know that's another aspect that goes
on in the nfl there's a lot of like very
religious people
involved in that i'm not saying right or
wrong but we know at times that can be
judged without
so there's there's a lot there and
that's where it's even it's still
it's incredibly courageous that he's put
himself
out here on a limb like this you know
and it's good i'm not trying to say that
but yeah there's going to be some
negativity and
and some obstacles to overcome because
of this as well
i think that's the most challenging part
of this to the extent that there are
people who have
genuinely held religious beliefs that
maybe they don't articulate because they
understand it's not a popular thing to
articulate yeah
but people who genuinely believe that it
is a sin that the bible forbids it
and and and you know my approach has
always been
i don't care what you do more elbow room
for me in heaven
i don't care i you know make your own
decision as to which commandments you're
going to follow or not but there
is an element that not only believes
it's a sin but feels compelled to tell
you
that you're a sinner and to view you
differently because you're doing
something that they regard as a sin well
it's not i don't really think it's my
business if someone else is sinning
that's just the way i've you think yeah
but you could see
a sliver of the nfl
overall environment right that not only
thinks privately well that's a sin
but also feels compelled to judge on top
of it
that's where it becomes i think very
tricky
and very delicate and that's i get back
to the owners need to step in
yeah because and this is another
conversation all together yeah
but religion has no business in an nfl
locker room either i'm sorry it doesn't
i cringe every time
people think you're you're
anti-christian when you say this i'm not
i'm christian
but i also practiced law for 20 years
and i also believe
in the first amendment and i believe in
separation of church and state
and i believe that that you should not
be required to be a christian to be on a
football team agreed
and and there are too many times where
the message is we want
christians on this team that's not how
it should be folks
that's not how it should be no it
definitely should not be i i'm with you
i never felt comfortable with that
aspect of the nfl locker room when they
did have something like that
you know in there where it was like you
know again not that
i'm not the most religious person i grew
up in a catholic household
but yeah i'm not right now nor did i
want to really hear about it when i was
at work to your point
you know i didn't nor did i want to be
judged maybe because i didn't get in a
special group in the locker room to get
on a knee in prayer and pray
like i didn't you know and then yeah so
the
locker room's a weird place there's it's
all over the place
and it is a little bit of a you know
microcosm of
like you talked about already what we
have in our country yeah you're gonna
have pockets in the locker room and be
like okay yeah he's gay who cares like i
don't care
i mean there's probably other gay guys
in the locker room and i probably have
gay friends that i don't know about or
whatever
but then you're gonna have others in
that locker room who are they're not
gonna say it
but they're gonna have their own little
group
that is not going to love it and they'll
be cordial and hey carl and all that
but i don't think they're going to be
inviting them over to barbecues or
anything like that either
years ago i had a case against a
business where that
forced christianity just oozed from
management throughout the entire
organization
and there was an employee who wasn't on
board with it and when that employee got
fired
we we made them understand what is
permitted and not permitted
in a workplace and there is a wall that
needs to be respected but
we're mentioning all this because i
think we've identified the one way that
this can still be a problem
for carl nasib in nfl locker room if
ownership
general manager team president
aren't willing or able to make sure the
head coach understands
what should and shouldn't be going on in
his locker room yeah that's it
plain and simple that hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports